[موسيقى]
هون الدنيا اكلت منا
مرحبا موضوعنا اليوم عن واحد من اكثر
الاعمال حصدا للثناء النقدي في رمضان وهو
مسلسل مربى العيسى حيث يعود العمل الى
القرن الماضي وحارات الشام العريقه مع
كوكبه من المع النجوم ضمن احداث تدور او
وقائعها في مدينه دمشق عام 19 حول قصص
ثلاث حارات وهي الورد المشرقيه والعسليه
ملكه شخصيه بسيطه كتير
وزكيه كتير
بساطتها انها ممكن تقول
اشياء ممكن تسبب ازمات لكن هي
بالحنكه تبعها تحولها لحل وهذا الشي كثير
نادر بهالايام زائد انه هي نموذج نسائي ما
نعرض اظن
واللي هو البزنس ومن بهداك الوقت كيف
امراه شاميه عم تاسس حالها من الصفر وحاطه
تارجت وماشيه عليه وبدها توصل لاهدافها
حتى لو هي مو معلمه الوقت بس هي عندها من
الذكاء ما يكفي من اسمه
من اسمه هيك بيعطيك دلاله لشيء هو ببساطه
عم يحكي عن حدا ظلمته الحياه كتير اجت
عليه كتير تعب بس ما اخلى الحياه تكسره
لانه
يتغلب على كل المصاعب اللي مرق فيها ويوصل
لهدفه يعني
وغيرها من القيم الجميله من تاليف علي
معين صالح واخراج رشاش وبدي وبطوله محمود
نصر عباس النوري امل عرفه سوزان نجم الدين
خالد القيش نادين تحسين بيك فادي صبيح
وغيرهم وبحسنا كتير بالتفاصيل عن المستوى
الاماكن على مستوى الملابس
حاولنا نشوف هاي البيئه بهذا الزمن قديش
كانت جميله بتعرف مواصفات العمل الرمضاني
خاصه شوي بيكون فيها جرعه الميلودراما
جرعه العواطف كثير عاليه نتوقف الان معاه
ابرز ما جاء من تعليقات الجمهور حول
المسلسل
[موسيقى]
وانا بعينك
وكل شيء بهالدنيا ان شاء الله هيتغير
بيننا وبين الحقيقه شهر وحده
[تصفيق]
طبعت المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات